AI never sleeps and this week has been
absolutely
insane. We have a new realtime video
generator that can run on a consumer
GPU. We also have a real-time
texttospech generator that's super
lightweight. It can run on any CPU or
even just your mobile phone. Bite Dance
continues to cook this week by releasing
an incredible state-of-the-art AI model.
We have an open- source thought to text
AI. This can analyze your brain waves
and figure out what you're thinking.
This open- source AI can generate videos
that are 2K or even 4K in resolution.
Alibaba releases their best model yet,
Quen 3.5. Google also drops their best
model, Gemini 3.1 Pro. Plus, they also
released an incredible and free music
generator. This AI can turn your prompt
into a full 4D scene. We have some
ridiculous humanoid robot demos and a
lot more. So, let's jump right in. First
up, Alibaba releases their most
performant model yet, Quen 3.5. This is
a multimodal model that has 397
billion parameters. But when you use it,
only 17 billion parameters are active,
so it's quite efficient. And like the
top models out there, this is especially
good at reasoning, coding, agentic
abilities, and multimodal understanding.
The really awesome thing is this has a
million token context window. So this is
like how much information you can fit
into your prompt at once. And a million
tokens is among the largest in the
industry. You can fit like over 700,000
words or a medium-sized codebase or over
an hour of video into your prompt at
once. And if you look at these
benchmarks, it's very impressive. So,
it's really good at instruction
following, also graduate level science
questions as well as agentic abilities.
And also, it's really good at document
recognition and video reasoning. So like
overall it's as good as some of the top
closed models out there like GPT,
Claude, and Gemini. The awesome thing is
because this is multimodal, it doesn't
just have to work with text, but this
can also take in images and video. So
you can just upload an entire video and
ask it questions about the video or even
get it to create a PowerPoint
presentation like this. Or here's an
example of a racing game that it has
coded up. This is actually the most
impressive 3D racing game I've seen so
far. like the other models aren't able
to get this level of detail. And of
course, it's also great at front-end
design. For example, we can get it to
create a sunscreen product website. And
here's the result. And of course, you
can also link this to OpenClaw as the
model to use. And then you can prompt it
to do stuff via WhatsApp or Telegram.
So, here's an example of that. This is
also really good at spatial awareness
and understanding. So, if we upload this
image and we ask, is the telephone booth
on the left or right side of the yellow
van? This is actually a quite tricky
photo because the yellow van is pointing
north. So, the telephone booth is
actually to the right of the yellow van
even though the rest of the cars on this
lane are facing south. So, it has to
reason a lot, but eventually it does end
up with the correct answer. Or you can
also upload this maze and get it to find
the shortest path and it's able to pull
up Python and code up an algorithm to
find the shortest path. And here's our
result. A really cool thing is you can
even get it to solve sudoku puzzles
which a lot of top models aren't able to
do well. So you can just upload this
image of a Sudoku puzzle and then it
would proceed to solve it for you. The
awesome thing is they've actually open
sourced this. So if you click on this
GitHub repo and you scroll down a bit
here, it contains all the instructions
on how to download and run this locally
on your computer. Now note that with 397
billion parameters, this is quite huge.
This is 87 GB in size. So you're not
going to be able to run this on most
consumer devices unless you have your
own data farm. But that being said, this
is one of the best open- source models
you can use right now. Even if you can't
download this locally, you can also use
this online for free via their Quen chat
platform. So on this model dropdown, you
can select these Quen 3.5 models.
Anyways, if you're interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Also, this week
we have an open-source Genie 3. So this
is called Anchorwave, and this can
generate interactive world videos. In
other words, this is a video where you
can press the WD or arrow keys and move
around this 3D world. So, it just takes
a starting initial frame and then you
can generate a 3D world from that where
you can move around. Now, currently for
one iteration, it can only generate 81
frames, which is roughly a few seconds,
but you can iterate this multiple times
to create a longer video. The really
impressive thing is it can maintain
consistency and realism over a long
period of time. Here are some other
examples for your reference. Notice that
this is much better than previous
interactive world generators in that
this one actually preserves a memory of
the scene. So even if you look away and
then you look back, everything remains
the same as before. And then here are a
few other examples. And as you can see,
it doesn't just have to work in a
first-person view. You can also upload a
thirderson perspective like this. And it
can also generate a third person video
of this character moving around. The key
to anchor weave is that it uses a
special technique called local geometric
memories to generate the video. This
means it breaks down the scene into
smaller parts and uses these parts to
create a consistent and realistic video
that preserves the overall 3D
configuration of the scene. It also uses
what's called a multi-anchor weaving
controller to help combine these parts
coherently and generate a smooth video.
Now, if you compare Anchorwave with
other 3D scene generators, notice that
it's just a lot more coherent and
detailed compared to the other methods.
So, here's one example, and then the
ground truth is on the lower right.
Anchorwave is actually very similar to
the ground truth or here's another
example for your reference. The awesome
thing is if you scroll up to the top of
the page, they've already released the
code to this. So, if you click on this
GitHub repo, it contains all the
instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. Note that
currently this initial model is based
off of an older video generator called
Cogvideo X, but they're also planning to
release a one-based example in the
future as well, which should be better
in quality. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this AI is is very
useful. It's called Tiny A by Coher
Labs. And like the name implies, this is
quite a small and open weights model
which can help you translate stuff or
respond to you in many different
languages. So this is incredibly tiny.
This is only like 3.35 billion
parameters. So this is even small enough
to run on consumer hardware or even your
mobile phone. And this model knows over
70 languages. So that's the base model.
And then they fine-tuned it further to
create this tiny AA global model. And
this can support 67 languages. Here are
the 67 languages that are supported by
tiny AA global from five regions of the
world. So here's a benchmark on
multilingual generation quality
comparing tiny AA with other
similarsized models across languages
from all these different regions. And as
you can see on average, tiny AA performs
better. This is also incredibly
efficient. So in this graph the y-axis
is the generation quality. The higher
the better. And then the yaxis is the
number of parameters. So the smaller the
better. Ideally, you want to be in this
upper left corner. And as you can see,
tiny aa is over here. Now, you can try
this out on hugging face for free right
now. So, it looks like this. Here are
some examples for your reference. Here's
an example of a Spanish prompt. And as
you can see, it answers incredibly fast
because this is very tiny. Or here's
another example where the prompt is
Arabic. And again, it's able to answer
you incredibly fast. Or here's a Chinese
example. And here is an example where we
get it to translate a sentence from
Basque to French and it's able to do
this very well. The awesome thing is
this is open weight. So they've already
released the model on hugging face. And
here you can see that at least for the
tiny AA global model, this is quite tiny
at only 6.7 GB in size. So this can fit
comfortably on most consumer GPUs.
Anyways, if you're interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Also this week,
we have an incredibly lightweight
texttospech generator called Kitten TTS.
This is incredibly tiny. Here it says
it's under 25 megabytes and it's only 15
million parameters, not even a billion
parameters. So, this essentially allows
you to even run this on just a normal
CPU or even just your mobile phone. You
don't even need a GPU to run this. And
it's so lightweight that you can even
run this in real time with just mediocre
hardware. Kitten TTS. The super tiny and
expressive open- source models are back
with an upgrade.
>> This time we're launching three tiny
models, an 80 million, 40 million, and
the smallest one with just 14 million
parameters.
>> Our smallest model is less than 25
megabytes and can run on minimal
hardware. This clip was actually
produced by it.
>> These were built with love by a tiny
team of kittens. We're working on
packing Frontier Intelligence into tiny
models.
>> Check it out on GitHub and connect with
us on our Discord community.
>> In fact, they already released a free
online demo on hugging face for you to
try this out. So, for example, let's try
these two tricky sentences. And here we
can choose from the smallest model, the
medium-sized one, or the largest one.
Let's just go with the default
medium-sized model. And then here we can
choose from a list of different voices.
Notice that right now you can't clone
your own voice. So you can only choose
from their preset voices. And then here
you can choose the speed of the
generation. And that's pretty much it.
So let's click on generate. And here's
our result.
>> The record producer refused to record
the band's new single. The wind was too
strong to wind the kite string around
the spool.
>> All right. So it's not bad for a super
tiny 40 million parameter model. The
awesome thing is they've released all
the models already. If you click on the
largest one, this is only 80 megabytes
in size. though even this can fit
comfortably on like a CPU or you can
even fit this just on your phone. And
then the smallest one is only 25
megabytes in size. Super tiny. And then
down here it contains all the
instructions on how to install and run
this locally. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this news is pretty
insane. So, this company is called Talis
and they just unveiled this chip which
is incredibly fast and efficient. It
achieves 17,000 tokens per second. If
you don't know what that means, here is
a chart comparing the tokens per second
or basically the output rate of this
Talis HC1 chip compared to the
industryleading chips out there. This
includes Cerebrus or Gro or even
Nvidia's state-of-the-art B200 which is
all the way down here. So, this is like
40 times faster than Nvidia's
state-of-the-art chips. And get this,
not only is it faster, but it also costs
20 times less to build and it consumes
10 times less power. So, how exactly
does this work? You see, an AI model is
basically a neural network. This is
currently made of code and this code
lives in software. For example, a
transformer could live in this PyTorch
code. Now, this software needs to be
powered by hardware in order to run. But
because of this disconnect between
software and hardware, it's not as
efficient. But here, what Talis has done
is they've basically hardcoded the AI
model, specifically Llama 3.1, onto the
chip itself. So this AI model that lives
inside this chip can now respond to you
in real time as fast as the speed of
thought. You don't even need to wait for
the sentence to complete. And I think
this would be the future of AI models.
We need custom hardware that's designed
specifically for these AI models so that
they can be hard-coded into these chips.
This design merges memory and
computation together all on just one
chip which unifies the entire system.
You don't need any big cooling or
complicated components. And this helps
cut down the costs significantly and
also make it way faster. But here's the
main problem I have with this. So this
chip is built specifically for Llama
3.1. It's not going to work if you add
DeepSeek or Quen or another AI model
onto this. So at least currently the
technology is that you need to build a
chip specifically for each model. But I
think this is definitely going to be the
future where we have AI living directly
in hardware instead of software and this
is just the beginning. Anyways, if
you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main release page in
the description below. Also, this week
we had Lunar New Year. So, of course,
China hosted their annual spring
festival gala event. And here they
showcased some insane abilities from the
Unitere G1 robot. This is a huge
improvement compared to last year. Here
you can see some clips of the rehearsal
or training of these robots as well as
the live performance. And as you can
see, it's able to do some insanely
acrobatic stuff. I mean, these robots
are able to jump like two to 3 m into
the air, executing full flips or even
multiple sequential flips. Some of them
can even perform continuous single leg
flips and also run up a wall and flip.
This is crazy. This is actually really
impressive because jumping and flipping
requires some explosive actuator torque
that pushes the absolute limits of
robotic hardware. And the hardest part
actually isn't even the jump, but the
landing. The robot must calculate its
mid-air orientation in real time and
anticipate the exact moment of impact
and then instantly absorb the massive
kinetic force through its leg joints to
prevent, you know, bouncing or slipping.
So, not only does this require explosive
power, but also incredible balance, but
as you can see, they've programmed the
Uni Tree robot to do this very well. In
fact, they even have one robot
intentionally wobble and act like it's
drunk and then falling on its back. But
within a split second, it was able to
spring back up like this. That was
actually intentional. And then here we
have some demos of multiple robots using
these nunchucks, which again is actually
very hard. So this fundamentally alters
the robot's center of gravity and
momentum with every swing. So the robot
needs to constantly recalculate and
recalibrate these forces to remain
balanced. And then here's another demo
from Unree of the rehearsal and training
process of these robots. And this is
another really impressive feature. You
can see right now this swarm of dozens
of robots are controlled by one system.
They need to rapidly move around into
these tight coordinations to spell out
specific shapes or characters.
Controlling one robot is hard enough,
but networking dozens of them requires
this centralized swarm intelligence
system with near zero latency. So, here
they're showcasing how you can now
deploy not just one robot, but multiple
robots in large synchronized fleets for
like mass industrial or logistical
operations. A pretty crazy demo. Also
this week, this AI is very useful. It's
called Louv, and this can generate ultra
highresolution videos. So, you just need
to enter a text prompt, but as you can
see, this can generate some really
detailed and highquality videos. It's
much better than the other top open-
source alternatives we have like LTX2
and 1 2.2. So, here's an example of a
bee on a flower. And this is just a 2K
example. I'm also going to show you some
4K examples in a second. As you can see
here, even like each strand of hair on
the bee is visible. This is how detailed
the video is. Or here's another example
of a lion fish swimming in coral. And
again, note how detailed this whole
video is. Super impressive. Right now,
those were just some 2K examples. Here
we have some 4K examples. Look how crisp
and clear everything is. You can even
see the ripples of the water if you look
closely. This isn't just like a fake 4K
video that's actually 1080p. This does
actually look like 4K. And then here's
another superdetailed example of this
row of camels walking in the desert.
Here's another example for your
reference. Again, you can even make out
the minute details of the waves hitting
the shoreline. Very impressive. Now, if
you compare this with other video
generators or upscaling methods, notice
that by far this new model outperforms
the rest across all these different
benchmarks. Now, at the top of the page,
they do have some buttons for a GitHub
repo and data, but these don't link to
anything yet. Hopefully, they will open
source this for now. If you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. I've been covering a ton of video
generators lately. There's Cling 3 and
now Seed Dance. And just to let you in
on a little secret, there's going to be
more crazier models coming soon. If
you're feeling overwhelmed from better
models coming week after week, then
Higsfield, the sponsor of this video,
would be a great option. It brings
together the best image and video
generators all in one place. You can use
the best available video model. Cling 3,
and of course, the legendary Seed Dance
2.0 will be available as soon as
possible. One of my favorite things
about Higsfield is their preset
templates library. you can just grab
something right out of the box and start
creating. Some popular ones include the
skin enhancer preset or this clothes
swapper or this relighting preset. There
are also a ton of camera movement
presets which you can easily use to make
your generations even more cinematic.
Plus, they have a new Vive Motion
feature which allows you to easily
generate motion graphics. Simply start
with a prompt and you can optionally add
a reference image or a video. Hicksfield
then generates a professional polished
motion design right away. If you're
looking for one unified platform that
has all the best image and video
generators, so you can easily create
assets without switching between sites,
Higsfield is one of the best options to
use. Try it for free using the link in
the description below and stay tuned for
Seed Dance 2.0. They're going to be the
first to release it when it comes out.
Next up, this AI is pretty wacky. So,
it's called Zuna Thought to Text and
apparently it can scan your thoughts or
basically your brain waves and translate
that into what you're actually thinking.
Here are the specs. This is a 380
million parameter BCI foundation model
for EEG data. So, EEG stands for
electrophalogram
and this is basically a way to measure
electrical activity of the brain using
small sensors or electrodes attached to
your scalp. And so this is basically an
AI model that's able to analyze and
translate this EEG data. Now, when you
connect these electrodes to your scalp
and generate these electric signals,
here is what the EEG data looks like.
And this data by itself, it's really
hard to analyze what exactly this is.
Typically, these signals can be very
messy and noisy. Plus, the electrode
layout could be different between
different subjects and different places.
Plus, you could have some channels
missing. Anyways, all this data is
really messy. So, the point of this Zuna
model is to dn noiseise this EEG data.
In other words, clean it up and also
reconstruct any missing channels and
also predict new channel signals based
on current data. Now, currently, this
does not directly turn EEG data into
text. So, it's not that good yet. It
can't just magically interpret what
you're thinking from this graph. The
point of this currently is to clean up
the data or reconstruct missing data and
also add higher resolution to this data.
So think of this as like the first
open-source foundation model for brain
signals. This is just the start and the
long-term vision for this is to
eventually of course just take this raw
brainwave data and convert it into text
on what the person is thinking. Anyways,
the awesome thing is they've released
the model weights already. So, if you
click on this GitHub repo, it contains
all the instructions on how to download
and run this locally on your computer.
Note that it's actually quite tiny. So,
the model is less than 2 GB in size, so
you can fit this comfortably within most
consumer devices. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this AI is super
powerful. It's called Audio X and this
is a unified model that can generate
audio and music from a ton of different
inputs. You can input text, images, or
even videos and get it to generate audio
from that. So, here are some examples.
First of all, here are some text to
audio examples. So, you can easily
prompt this to generate sound effects.
Here is Thunder and Rain during a sad
piano solo.
Very nice. And then here are some ocean
waves crashing.
Now you can add more specific details to
your prompt. For example, a machine gun
fires twice followed by a period of
silence, then the sound of waves and
surf. Let's hear what this sounds like.
And it followed this very well. Or
here's another example. Fireworks burst
twice followed by a period of silence
before a clock begins ticking.
Very cool. Now text to sound effects is
just simple stuff. Here we also have
some text to music examples. So here is
a suspenseful scene in a haunted
mansion.
That does sound pretty scary. And then
here's an uplifting ukulele tune for a
travel vlog.
The quality is mediocre. You can
probably get away with using this for
some background music. Or here is some
smooth urban R&B beat with a mellow
groove.
Now in text to music, that's just simple
stuff. We already have some really good
quality music generators out there. So,
that wasn't too impressive. But in
addition, this can also take in video as
input and generate audio from that. So,
here's the final generation of the video
plus its generated audio stitched
together.
Notice that it's able to actually detect
the exact time when there was a cut in
the video and then generate the
appropriate audio for that. Here's
another tricky example.
Or here's another example.
Now, in addition to inputting a video,
you can also input audio and get it to
repair certain sections. For example,
here if we have this original audio clip
where the middle part is deleted. Let's
hear what this sounds like first. Thank
you.
All right. So, there was some silence in
the middle. Well, we can just inpaint
this middle section with some brief
speech followed by loud applause and
cheering. And here is our result.
As you can hear, it's quite seamless.
You can barely tell like when it's
actually filling in this part. Now,
similarly, instead of filling in the
middle, you can also use this to extend
an audio clip. So, for example, here is
the original audio.
And then let's get it to continue this.
The prompt would be action-packed
orchestral music. And here's the result.
Now, those were just some examples. The
audio quality isn't great, to be honest,
but it's really impressive how it's able
to take in so many different types of
inputs. This is truly a unified audio
model. And if you compare this with
other competitors, notice that this one
by far outperforms the rest in terms of
not only performance, but the amount of
abilities that this has. It can do
pretty much everything from text to
audio, text to music, video to music,
image to audio, inpainting, etc., etc.
The awesome thing is they've released
this already. So if you click on this
GitHub repo, this contains all the
instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. This is
quite a small model. So, the model size
is less than 6 GB, so you should be able
to fit this comfortably with most
consumer GPUs. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this AI is quite
interesting. It's called Veto Pix, and
this is a quite unique way of editing
images. So, here's how it works. It
would basically convert your image into
vector shapes like this and then you can
edit each vector shape individually and
then from that it would reconstruct the
final image like this. If you do want to
like really control the shape or
composition of certain things in the
image, then this might be a good way to
do so. So here's another example where
we can stretch out this mountain and set
it to the exact shape that we want and
regenerate the image from this vector
reference. Now, this doesn't just have
to change the shape of stuff. You can
also select a certain element and then
change the color of the vector and it
would apply the color change like this.
Here's a cool example where we can
convert this image into a vector and
then move the rose vector somewhere
else. And here's our results. So, this
is really good for like moving or
repositioning objects in a photo. The
cool thing about working with vectors is
you can also add additional vectors on
top of your image. So for example, we
can add this vector of sunglasses onto
this and then here's what we get. Or we
can also remove anything from an image.
For example, we can remove this
toothbrush vector and here is our
result. Or you can just add any other
image onto this vector render like this
and it would still work. It can
seamlessly add that object into your
photo. Now, given that we already have
Nano Banana Pro and also Quinn ImageEdit
and other state-of-the-art image editors
where you can just simply edit any image
you want with a text prompt, I think
this method might be overkill unless you
really want to microedit something in
the image to be of a certain shape or
position. But if this is of interest to
you, then at the top of the page, it
does say the code is coming soon.
Currently, this doesn't link to anything
yet, but if you are interested, I'll
link to this main page in the
description below for you to read
further. Next up, this AI is really
cool. So, this can generate 4D scenes,
in other words, 3D videos or simulations
just from a text description. So, it's
basically a chatbot where you can just
enter a prompt and it would create an
entire 3D scene which you can edit
further in Blender. Here's an example.
Here we have a breeze stirs through the
autumn forest, gently swaying the entire
tree as leaves dance in the wind. And
here's our result. Here is a full 3D
scene that can move over time. Or here's
another example. Here's a 10-second
time-lapse capturing the transition from
warm pre-dawn to sunrise followed by a
midday sunlight through a green canopy,
golden late afternoon light, etc., etc.,
and it's able to generate this 3D scene
of a time-lapse very accurately. Or
here's lush green forest with heavy
rainstorm. And then here's a vibrant
underwater scene with a translucent
jellyfish, etc., etc. Pretty cool.
Here's another example where we have
some chopped trees burning fiercely in
this dark forest. Now, of course, this
can also generate indoor scenes with
different actions. For example, here we
have this tall ceramic cup which tips on
its side, spilling water and flooding
the tabletop as it flows toward the edge
and drips down. Or here's another indoor
example. Here we have a cozy bedroom
with warm lighting. Notice that
everything in the scene is 3D. You can
edit any object further using some 3D
editing software like Blender. Or here
we have a brown glass bottle rolling
slowly across the living room floor. If
you click on this GitHub repo and you
scroll down a bit, it seems like they
will release the code to this soon. And
then here it contains all the
instructions on how to get started.
Anyways, if you're interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. All right, next
up. This AI is pretty crazy. What if I
told you that we can now get realtime
video generation on just a single RTX
1590? Well, this AI called Monarch RT
does exactly that. This can generate
true realtime video at 16 frames per
second on just a single consumer GPU,
specifically the RTX 5090. Now, I know
this is still a pretty high-end GPU, but
hey, at least you don't need like a data
farm to run this. It's still pretty
affordable. And by the way, speaking of
the RTX 5090, I'm actually doing a
giveaway of this. So, make sure you
watch to the end to learn about the full
details of the giveaway. Now, if you
compare this to another acceleration
method called flash attention, notice
that Monarch RT is almost four times as
fast. Now, you might think that with
such a fast generator, you might see
some degradation in quality, but that's
actually not true. So if you compare
this with dense attention which is like
a video generation at full quality with
the same prompt here it says it's able
to reach like 95% of the quality of
this. So at the bottom is this new
monarch real time and as you can see the
quality is very similar. Here are some
other examples for your reference. The
awesome thing is at the top of the page
they've already released the code to
this. So, if you click on this GitHub
repo and you scroll down a bit here, it
contains all the instructions on how to
download and run this locally on your
computer. Anyways, if you're interested
in reading further, I'll link to this
main page in the description below.
Also, this week, Google releases their
best and latest model, Gemini 3.1 Pro.
Now, this is just an incremental
upgrade. It's just 3.1. It's not Gemini
4, but nevertheless, this is incredibly
powerful, and it already tops
independent leaderboards, as you can see
here. Plus, the price is extremely cheap
compared to other closed source
competitors. And the awesome thing about
Gemini is it's multimodal. Not only can
it understand text, but also images,
audio, and video. Now, I already did a
full review video on it, so I'm not
going to repeat too much here. See this
video if you want to learn more. But in
addition to Gemini 3 Pro, Google also
released an insane music generator
called LIIA 3. This is completely free
to use. You can use it right now on the
Gemini platform or app. So on the Gemini
app, simply click on create music and
then here you can just enter a prompt to
describe your track or you can even
upload an image to guide the generation.
So here's an example where I just
uploaded this image of a barbecue and
then asked it to make a song based on
the image and then it composed this. Let
me play this for you. Sun's going down,
the grill is hot. Flipping burgers for
the whole dang lot. Got that blueg grass
blasting on the speakers loud. So raise
them up. We're feeling proud.
Yeah, this is what it's all about.
Good friends and good times on a Friday
night. Everything is feeling right.
Yeah, feeling right.
All right, so that was the song for this
image. Let me know in the comments below
if it fits the image. Or here's another
example where I uploaded this image and
then asked it to make a J-pop song about
this image. And here is what I got.
Going
racers.
precious time.
We are the winding road racers.
All right, so it wasn't too bad, but
there you go. Here's a high energy J-pop
example based on this image. Now, this
can do a ton of other styles. So, for
example, here is some retro synth wave
tonight.
Oh, the neon dreams.
It seems
>> or here are some Hindi lyrics in pop
ballad style.
Amen.
Make
me
or here are some Spanish lyrics in funk
and city pop style. Fore! Foreign!
Foreign!
And then here are some other styles for
your reference.
>> Oh baby, it's been a long cold winter
walking. The wind is up and the sail is
set. Give away
the finest crew.
>> City lights are bleeding through the
rain. We're dancing in the memories
behind.
>> Here are some other examples of songs
generated from different images.
>> Pain salt on your skin in the snow.
Everything
is fine.
>> Now, like I said, this should already be
available on the Gemini platform or app.
You should see a button down here to
create music. Anyways, if you're
interested in checking this out, I'll
link to this main announcement page in
the description below. Now, last week,
Bite Dance releases a monster of a video
generator called Seed Dance 2.0. This is
by far the best video generator out
there. It's not even close. But this
week, they've continued to cook by
releasing another state-of-the-art model
called Seed 2. This is a large language
model. So, just like the top models out
there, this is especially good in terms
of multimodal understanding, reasoning,
and agentic capabilities. Here are some
benchmarks for your reference comparing
CE2 Pro on the far left with the top
models out there, including Claude, GPT
5.2, and Gemini 3. Here are some
benchmarks on visual reasoning. And as
you can see, C2 actually outperforms the
other closed models in most cases. And
then, same with motion and perception.
For instruction following, it's not as
good. It's like on par. And then same
with real world tasks. Now, because this
is so good at visual understanding, we
can upload this image and get Python to
plot this out and make it as similar as
possible. So afterwards, it under goes
some deep thinking. And then here is the
final result. It looks very similar to
the uploaded image. Or here we're
basically getting C 2.0 to autonomously
click and do stuff on a computer. So
here we're getting it to operate this
free CAD platform to edit and manipulate
3D objects. And as you can see, it's
actually doing all of this autonomously
step by step. And as you can see here,
it has done like almost 100 steps
sequentially. So this is really good for
like long horizon tasks. Now, I've been
scanning some independent leaderboards
to see if they've added seed 2.0 yet,
and at least for LM Arena, they have. So
in terms of text, Ced 2.0 ranks number
five. And then for vision, which C 2.0
is especially good at, this ranks number
four, still behind Gemini 3 and 3.1.
Now, currently, you can only use this
via this Volcano Engine API, but if
you're interested in checking this out
further, I'll link to it in the
description below. And that sums up all
the highlights in AI this week. Let me
know in the comments what you think of
all of this. Which piece of news was
your favorite? And which tool are you
most looking forward to trying out?
Thanks for watching and if you enjoyed
this video, remember to like and
subscribe. And if you've made it to
here, I've got a treat for you. I'm
partnering with Nvidia to give away an
RTX 5090 GPU around their GTC 2026
event. With this, you can easily run AI
tools locally on your computer. Here's
how to enter. Simply click the link in
the description to register and attend
at least one GTC 2026 session, which
will be on March 16th to 19th. You can
attend virtually or in person. Here are
some of my favorites. Jensen Huang's
keynote is an obvious one, but this one
on humanoid robots at scale as well as
this one on openw world models are also
on my watch list. Again, make sure you
sign up for GTC using the link in the
description below. And then afterwards,
fill out the form and you're good to go.
It's totally free to